ZDF volter live herzlich willkommen zu
unserem Ukraine Updat in dieser Woche im
Süden und im Osten der Ukraine gibt es
weiter schwere Kämpfe die russischen
Truppen versuchen weiter die Stadt
avdivka im Osten einzunehmen unter
erheblichen Verlusten gleichzeitig
gelingt es den ukrainischen Truppen
offenbar im Süden an der befreiten Stadt
Cherson die Russen weiter
zurückzudrängen und die Stellung südlich
des Flusses niprov in der von Russland
besetzten Seite weiter zu festigen unser
Reporter Tim Kröger der war heute in
Cherson wo in einem Vorort laut
ukrainischen Angaben heute drei Menschen
durch russischen Beschuss ums Leben
gekommen sind Tim wird uns gleich von
seinen Eindrücken berichten außerdem bei
uns im Stream heute der Militärexperte
Gustav gressel den wir unter anderem
fragen wollen welche Hoffnung machen
unter anderem die Meldung aus rerson für
die ukrainische Gegenoffensive wie ist
der aktuelle Stand in der Schlacht um
avdka und wie bereiten sich die
Zivilbevölkerung und auch die
Streitkräfte auf den Winter vor eure
Fragen und Gedanken zum Thema könnt ihr
wie immer sehr gerne direkt im Chat
stellen oder ihr schickt sie uns per
Mail an
zdfheute-live@zdf.de und ich versuche
dann so viele wie möglich hier im Stream
unterzubringen und auch an Gustav
gressel weiterzugeben und in Berlin
begrüße ich jetzt Gustav gressel er ist
Militärexperte beim European Council on
Foreign Relations guten Abend her
gressel guten Abend
also wir haben in den vergangenen Tagen
und Wochen immer wieder gehört dass die
Bodenoffensive auf beiden Seiten
weitgehend festgefahren sind auch immer
wieder von bedingt durch die schwierigen
Wetterbedingungen die aktuell herrschen
wo steht dieser Krieg aktuell ihre
Einschätzung nach für die Ukraine für
die Ukraine ist der Krieg jetzt in einer
enorm schwierigen Phase sie hat
ihr die Hoffnungen dass die
Gegenoffensive im Süden operativ
entscheidende Gelände Gewinne bringen
die hat sich bislang nicht erfüllt
die Unterstützer der Ukraine die USA
aber auch viele europäische Staaten
schwimmen entweder in politischen oder
in finanziellen Schwierigkeiten das
heißt man macht sich Sorgen wie lange
die Unterstützung der Ukraine durch den
Westen aufrechtterhalten werden kann und
in welchem Ausmaß durch vor allen Dingen
nordkoreanische Waffenlieferungen hat
die russische artillerietätigkeit wieder
stark zugenommen auch die russische
Luftwaffe ist deutlich aktiver als in
den letzten Monaten und das verhilft der
russischen Armee die Initiative vor
allen Dingen im Osten zurückzugelangen
im Süden hat die ukrainische Armee noch
zumindest teilweise die Initiative in
ihrer Hand und versucht jetzt die
Stellungen vor allen Dingen für diesen
langen Kriegswinter zu verbessern dass
dieser Kriegswinter aus ukrainischer
Sicht wird wahrscheinlich ein defensiver
man wird versuchen den Russen so wenig
wie möglich Gelände zu überlassen und
dafür so viel wie möglich an Verlusten
zuzufügen auf der russischen Seite äh
ist sozusagen der Vorteil der
Wintermonate dass gerade im Süden in
saaporisha in kerson das Wegenetz das
Eisenbahnnetz ein viel dünneres ist als
etwa im Donbass in donzka und ruhanska
Oblast das heißt die Versorgung der
Truppen dort mit Munition wird
schwieriger auf beiden Seiten
das Bewegen vor allen Dingen für
Radfahrzeuge die die Ukraine sehr viel
verwendet wird schwieriger auf der
anderen Seite im Donbass dadurch dass
das Gelände hügeliger ist und Wasser
schneller ab geführt wird und auch
dadurch dass es eine
schwerindustrieregion wird äh war das
heißt viele schwer befestigte Straßen
tragfeste Brücken und vor allen Dingen
Eisenbahnverbindungen vorhanden sind ist
also für eine russische Winteroffensive
so wir es auch im letzten Jahr gesehen
haben durchaus zuträglich und das
erwarten die Ukrainer jetzt sie haben
jetzt gerade gesagt bisher hat sich die
ukrainische Hoffnung da noch nicht so
ganz erfüllt wir wollen natürlich im
Laufe dieses Streams aber auch noch mal
darüber sprechen welche Hoffnung sich
die die Ukraine jetzt möglicherweise auf
Grundlage dieser Meldung die wir jetzt
auch R son bekommen machen können wir
wollen uns jetzt aber erstmal einen
Überblick verschaffen wo gerade gekämpft
wird und wie der Frontverlauf derzeit
aussieht und da hat meine Kollegin
Marion Geiger einmal den aktuellen
standand für euch
zusammengefasst dieses Video soll einen
Angriff der ukrainischen Armee zeigen
mit einem neuen drohnentyp und 4 kg
Sprengstoff in der Region Cherson auf
Russisch besetztem Territorium auch
diese Bilder sollen eine erfolgreiche
Attacke der Ukrainer belegen auf eine
Basis russischer Spezialkräfte in der
Region es sind intensive Kämpfe im Süden
des
Landes laut eigenen Angaben konnte das
ukrainische Militär mehrere Brückenköpfe
sichern am linken Ufer des Flusses npro
das eigentlich russisch besetzt ist von
dort aus versuchen die Ukrainer nun
russische Einheiten weiter
zurückzudrängen um ihre Städte am
anderen Ufer zu schützen
das russische Verteidigungsministerium
bestreitet dass die Ukrainer sich
festsetzen konnten und veröffentlicht
diese Bilder die ebenfalls den Krieg in
der Region herson zeigen sollen Moskau
spricht von hohen Verlusten der
ukrainischen
Armee 1000 Kilometer lang ist die Front
in afdivka verteidigt die Ukraine weiter
die Stadt und ist eigenen Angaben
zufolge in einer schwierigen Lage diese
Bilder aus einer russischen Quelle
sollen biet zeigen russische Truppen
versuchen offenbar weiter die Stadt
einzukesseln Herr Gresser lassen Sie uns
gerne einmal kurz bei avivka bleiben
also die russischen Truppen wir haben es
gerade auch im Beitrag gesehen Rücken
allmählich von beiden Flanken an die
belagerte Stadt heran angeblich unter
sehr massiven Verlusten wie schätzen Sie
die Lage dort bei aufdfka aktuell ein
sie ist für die Ukraine zunehmend
schwierig erstens die russischen
Vorstöße an den Flanken machen die
Versorgungswege eng desto enger die
Versorgungswege desto schwieriger ist es
Truppen rein und raus zu bewegen und
abzulösen und Truppen die lange nicht
abgelöst wurden ermüden mit der Zeit und
vor allen Dingen für die Evakuierung von
Verwundeten ist das auch ein Problem
weil verwundete innerhalb man sagt so
einer goldenen Stunde aus der Stad raus
evakuiert werden müssen sonst laufen sie
Gefahr zu verbluten bzw zu sterben es
ist jetzt wenn die wenn nur mehr wenige
sichere Verbindungslinien die durch den
Feind nicht einsehbar sind vorhanden
sind dann stauen sich dort die Fahrzeuge
die rein und raus müssen dann muss es
dann gibt es einen Konkurrenzkampf
zwischen sanitätsfahrzeugen unter
anfhrungszeichen und munitionstransport
dann ganz schlimm war das im bachmut in
den letzten Monaten März April letzten
Jahres das S auf divka noch nicht noch
nicht so schlimm aber es könnte sich äh
könnte sich
zuspitzen und dann steigen auf der
ukrainischen Seite die Verlust und das
ist das was im sinnees langen
abnutzungskrieges das ist was die
ukrainische Armee auf jeden Fall
vermeiden will deshalb gibt es innerhalb
der armeischen Stimmen die sagen wir
müssen eigentlich die Stadt aufgeben
oder wir sollten die Stadt bald aufgeben
politisch natürlich will man das seit
wie möglich hinauszögern erstens weil es
für die Moral schlecht ist zweitens
natürlich avdivka liegt im Norden von
donjetzk sehr nah am donjker flughen
ist sozusagen das nördliche Tor nach
Donk und ein Rückzug auf auf divka würde
natürlich ein Eingeständnis auch
bedeuten dass man so bald an eine
Befreiung Don jetzt nicht denken wird
können das Problem ist nur ähnlich wie
in bachmut kann über den Verlauf des
Winters natürlich da die Lage für die
ukrainische Seite schwierig werden ein
zweites erschwerendes Merkmal ist dass
der Kessel jetzt schon sehr eng ist und
deshalb weitreichende Fliegerabwehr
nicht im Kessel selber oder an den
Rennern stationiert werden kann weil
dazu die Nähe zu russischen Truppen zu
hoch ist die Chance dass so wertvolle
Systeme die man kaum nach bekommt von
russischen Drohnen erwischt werden und
das Rut nutzt die russische Luftwaffe um
Angriffe auf diesen auf auf DFK zu
fliegen vor allen Dingen durch den
Einsatz von gleitbomben und
Streumunition und die fügen natürlich
den Ukrainern sehr starke Verluste zu
und das ist für die Ukrainer auch im
Kampf sehr frustrierend dass man quasi
in der Zielscheibe der russischen
Luftwaffe sitzt und sehr WG wenig
Möglichkeiten hat dem zu entgehen man
gewinnt ja den Eindruck wenn man die
Geschehnisse dabei auf divka verfolgt
dass es die russische Führung offenbar
sehr eilig hat diese Stadt einzunehmen
warum das ist eine gute Frage natürlich
will die russische Armee über divka
hinaus
den donka Oblast zurück oder sozusagen
ganz
erobern auf DFK ist aus russischer Sicht
ein ein wundertorn in der Flanke sehr
nah an donjk
dran diese will man bereinigen das
zweite ist auf diefk wenn man auf die
Karte schaut sieht natürlich nach einer
guten Gelegenheit aus ukrainische Kräfte
einzukesseln bzw in Schwierigkeiten zu
bringen in der Praxis läuft es natürlich
nicht so glatt ab weil die ukrainische
Gegenwehr dort stark ist es sehr stark
stellungssysteme gibt viele Drohnen auf
der ukrainischen Seite die den Russen
natürlich enorm hohe Verluste beibringen
und das ist auch so ein bisschen die
Argumentation der Ukrainer die sagen wir
müssen ink sein noch bleiben die immens
hohen Verluste die die russische Armee
dabei erleidet vor allen Dingen bei dem
Versuch die Stadt schnell zu erobern und
schnell
einzukesseln die sind natürlich auch
etwas die der ukrainischen Seite helfft
dann mit so hohen Verlusten kann das
selbst Russland mit seiner
Kriegswirtschaft und seinen großen
Depots nicht sehr lange
durchhalten ich würde gerne noch eine
Frage von Youtube an Sie weitergeben
bevor wir dann nach her son schauen wie
ist denn die offizielle Bewertung zum
Zustand der russischen Armee aktuell in
Klammern Materialversorgung und Moral
was können Sie dazu
sagen sehr
heterogen es gibt sehr also es gibt
Einheiten die durchaus verstehen zu
kämpfen die auch das milisierte Personal
das sie bekommen haben gut integriert
haben die in den über einem Jahr der
seit der Mobilmachung verstrichen ist
das auch wirklich genutzt haben um
hinter der Front zu trainieren und dann
dementsprechend zu kämpfen andere
Einheiten das haben auch in der
ukrainischen
Gegenoffensive gesehen kollabieren wenn
der Druck zu groß
wird es gibt nach wie vor
führungsschwierigkeiten das Problem auf
der russischen Seite ist dass man zwar
Leute mobil machen kann aber dass die
Führer die Offiziere äh die diese
anführen sollen dass die auszubilden und
das sozusagen die Zeit bis die auch
wirklich eine frontreife haben dass die
natürlich lang ist
das ist nach wie vor ein Problem aber im
großen muss man sagen die russische
Armee wird besser ja sie wird sie trägt
auch ihre Angriffe
disziplinierter vor als noch vor einem
Jahr
die Koordination zwischen Luftwaffe und
bodenstreitkräften funktioniert weit
besser als das in der letzten
Winteroffensive vor einem Jahr
funktioniert hat und auch die Abstimmung
unter einzelnen Waffengattungen die Zeit
die in der Artilleriefeuer angefordert
wird funktioniert deutlich besser als
noch vor einem Jahr und das ist
natürlich für die ukrainische Seite ein
Problem denn quantitativ war die
russische Seite immer überleben aber die
qualitative Überlegenheit der Ukrainer
hat in den meisten Schlachten seit
Beginn dieses Krieges den Unterschied
gemacht und und diese qualitative
Überlegenheit die nähert sich leider
Gottes für aus ukrainischer Sicht immer
weiter an M Herr gressel dann lassen Sie
uns gerne einmal in den Süden der
Ukraine schauen nach her son wo die
Hoffnung der Ukraine auf militärische
Erfolge vielleicht größer ist die Stadt
wurde vor ziemlich genau einem Jahr von
den russischen Besatzern befreit ist
aber derzeit wieder unter massiven
russischen
Beschuss immer sozusagen dann von der
Seite von der südlichen Seite des nipro
wo die russischen Truppen ell sind
trotzdem meldet die Ukraine aktuell
militärische Erfolge und auch kleine
Geländegewinne wie sehen die aktuell aus
der nepro im Süden ist gekennzeichnet
durch große Aulandschaften auf der
linken Seite also auf der südlichen oder
oder östlichen Seite
wo die der die noch russisch besetzt ist
diese Aulandschaften erlauben es im
Grunde nicht sich mit größeren
Fahrzeugen darin zu bewegen
infanteriegelände hier hat die Ukraine
einen deutlichen Vorteil weil ihre
Infanteristen
in sowohl taktisch im imem Gefechts oder
gefechtstechnischen Verhalten besser
sind auch moralisch immer noch einen
eine sozusagen Überlegenheit haben dass
die Ukraine das Artilleriefeuer vom
Nordufer oder vom rechten Ufer des ne an
fordern kann auch die fliegeabwehr steht
auf diesem Ufer die diese Brückenköpfe
Schü und so konnten in den letzten
Wochen kleine Brückenköpfe immer weiter
ausgeweitet werden das Problem der
Ukrainer ist natürlich dann wenn es ins
befestigte Gebiet geht um man hat wenige
Ortschaften man hat wenige feste Straßen
undter eigener Kontrolle weil diese
Gegend dann natürlich den Russen erlaubt
mechanisierte Kräfte heranzuziehen und
hier mit höherer Feuerkraft zu wirken
aber im
zwischengelände spielen die die Ukraine
ihre Stärke aus auch hilft Ihnen hier
dass durch die Überflutung und durch die
Sprengung des kakovka staudams äh die
Vorbereitungen auf der russischen Seite
die defensiven Vorbereitungen die
Minenfelder die äh sperren zum Teil
weggeschwemmt und überschwemmt wurden
und dass natürlich die Vorbereitung
jetzt auf eine Verteidigung viel
improvisierter und schlechter ist als
das in anderen Teilen ähm des äh oblas
zisha oder oder kon wo die
Gegenoffensive im Sommer begonnen hat
und das hilft natürlich auch den
Ukrainern sich dort zu bewegen und dort
weiterzukommen wenn wir jetzt noch mal
beion bleiben sie haben es gerade
genannt wir haben es auch auf den Karten
auf der Animation gesehen es ist immer
die Rede von sogenannten Brückenköpfen
das ist ja ein sehr militärischer
Begriff können Sie uns einmal ganz kurz
beschreiben was damit gemeint
ist ein unter Brückenkopf also wie der
Name schon sagt versteht man darunter
einen eine Gegend in dem man später mal
vorh eine Brücke zu schlagen also im
Grunde wenn man sich den Fluss als
Teilung zwischen der ukrainischen Seite
und der russischen Seite anschaut dann
ist es sozusagen der Brückenkopf eine
kleine Delle auf der unter
Anführungszeichen russisch besetzten
Seite oder auf der russischen Seite und
der wo ukrainische Kräfte das uferhalten
sozusagen umringt von von russischen
Soldaten äh und
diese diese Delle in in sozusagen in die
russische Linie versucht man oder auf
dem anderen Ufer versucht man dann immer
weiter auszudehnen Brückenkopf deshalb
weil in der in der Vergangenheit oder
unter normalen Umständen man zuerst eben
diesen Brückenkopf sich holt und dann
mit pioniermitteln eine Brücke über den
Fluss schlägt um auch mit stärkeren
gepanzerten Verbänden darüber zu stoßen
das ist beim ne hier ein bisschen
schwieriger erstens weil dieser Fluss
riesig ist
und diese Aulandschaften die hier auf
der Karte wie so ein dünnes Band
ausschauen auch enorm dick sind und man
müsste ja nicht nur die Brücke über den
Fluss schlagen man müsste auch eine
Behelfsbrücke durch diese Aulandschaften
schlagen und befestigen und das wäre
natürlich ein lohnendes Ziel für die
russische Luftwaffe und für die
russische Artillerie
deshalb erfolgt hier der Transport über
kleine firschiffe und sturmboote äh die
eben auf das andere Ufer bringt und die
Infanterie hier einfach unter
Artillerieunterstützung vom anderen Ufer
kämpft Herr gressel wir haben dazu auch
eine Frage bekommen zu diesen
Brückenköpfen von Lukas Wendler bei
Youtube der fragt wie tief in Klammern
Kilometer muss der Brückenkopf am Dnipro
sein damit die Flussüberquerung in
größeren Verbänden gelingen
kann dazu muss man zum ersten Mal an
einen Brückenkopf mit einer guten
befestigten Straße rankommen das ist
hier nur bei krinki der Fall also es
gibt gibt einen Brückenkopf
äh und dann sollte man diesen
Brückenkopf
damit man
wirklich sozusagen ohne größere
Behinderungen rundgeht wenn man sich
anschaut die Reichweite eines
durchschnittlichen 122 mm
artilleriegeschosses ist etwa 23 km äh
nachdem die ja nicht direkt an der Front
stehen also wenn ich die Front so 10 15
km in die andere Richtung bewegt habe
kann man mit diesen sehr zahlreichen
Geschützen nicht mehr direkt auf die
auf die Brücke hinwirken dann habe ich
auch schon die Gelegenheit
äh Systeme der elektronischen
Kampfführung am anderen Ufer zu
platzieren die
vor allen Dingen Drohnen ausschalten und
stören damit die russische Seite nicht
beobachten kann wann diese Brücke
genutzt wird bzweise
also gerade bei Pionier oder bei
behälfsbrücken wenn ich z.B faerbrücken
habe oder oder oder fair Verbindungen
wann die fahren oder wo sie genau liegen
wenn weil die kann ich ja anders
verteuen oder ein bisschen verlegen
all das braucht eine einen gewissen Raum
der ist sehr stark geländeabhängig wie
gesagt
auch größere Gebiete die diese
Brückenköpfe sind zum Teil 8 km breit
und und mehrere Kilometer auch tief
das ist vom von der Gegend her an für
sich schon schon beachtlich das Problem
ist wie gesagt diese Gegend ist halt
großteils Sumpf da kann ich nichts
aufstellen da kann ich keine Artillerie
platzieren da kann ich keine LKWs äh
reinstellen da kann ich keine
Munitionsdepots anlegen weil es eben
Sumpf und Aulandschaft ist und desb ist
auch die die beachtliche Ausdehnung
dieser Brückenköpfe sagt noch nicht viel
aus wie ich sie wirklich verwenden kann
mhm Herr gressel wir wollen gleich noch
mal weiter sprechen dann auch über die
Hoffnung aus ukrainischer Perspektive
die jetzt eben von diesen kleinen
geländeewin gewinnen bei der Stadt Ron
ausgehen kann wir wollen jetzt aber
einmal nach ähm Odessa schalten zu
meinem Kollegen Tim Kröger der war
nämlich heute in Cherson und ist mir
jetzt wie gesagt aus Odessa zugeschaltet
hallo
Tim schönen guten Abend aus Odessa der
ukrainische Innenminister hat heute
Nachmittag mitgeteilt dass bei einem
russischen Angriff auf einen Vorort von
Cherson drei Menschen ums Leben gekommen
sein du warst heute in Cherson was hast
du von diesem Angriff
mitbekommen genau wir sind heute morgen
relativ früh nach reingefahren und
hatten dann im Laufe des Vormittags
erstmal eigentlich den Eindruck dass es
ein für
chonverhältnisse relativ ruhiger
Vormittag war aber als wir dann gegen
Mittag rausgefahren sind da haben wir
dann tatsächlich während wir dieser eine
ausfallsstraße entlang gefahren sind
zwei Explosionen gesehen eine sogar
direkt miterlebt die halt unmittelbar an
der Straße stattgefunden hat wenige 100
kilomet entfernt wir haben dann erstmal
relativ schnell versucht diese Gegend zu
verlassen dann haben dann eben erst im
Nachhinein erfahren dass bei diesen
Angriffen ganz offenbar drei Menschen
ums Leben gekommen sind es hat mehrere
Tote gegeben die ukrainische Seite sagt
auch dass dabei Streumunition eingesetzt
worden sei und es hat uns natürlich
einen Eindruck gegeben davon wie
schwierig die Verhältnisse sind vor
allem für die Menschen in rasson also
wie lebensgefährlich auch die Situation
für die Menschen in dieser Stadt sind
die dort ja mittlerweile seit
Kriegsbeginn eigentlich den
verschiedensten Bedrohungen ausgesetzt
sind das das ganze hat ja angefangen
kurz nach Kriegsbeginn mit der Besetzung
krassons durch russische Truppen für
einige Monate dann kam die Befreiung
dann aber kam eigentlich die ganze Zeit
über immer wieder heftiger Beschuss dann
im Juni dieses Jahres die Zerstörung des
stauderns die ja dazu geführt hat dass
rassonnen in Teilen schwer überflutet
worden ist auch das hat Zerstörung und
Leid mit sich gebracht also es ist
wirklich nur schwer vorstellbar wie
diese Menschen das alles dort ertragen
können und das ist wahrscheinlich auch
ein Grund dafür eben dass mittlerweile
diese Stadt von 280.000 Menschen
ursprünglich mittlerweile auf 70.000
Menschen die in dieser Stadt geblieben
sind geschrumpft sind also allein im
vergangenen Jahr sind 40.000 Menschen
evakuiert worden wir haben heute morgen
auch eine solche Evakuierung gefilmt und
haben mit den Menschen gesprochen und
sie haben uns eben gesagt dass diese
Angst dann doch eben irgendwann zu groß
wird dass sie größtenenteil die Zeit äh
des Tages im Inneren also in ihren
Wohnungen verbringen und dass eben
irgendwann dieser Zeitpunkt erreicht ist
dass man eben dann doch die Stadt
verlässt ähm das hängt auch ein bisschen
damit zusammen dass jetzt der Winter
kommt wie in der gesamten Ukraine
eigentlich wird befürchtet dass auch in
der Region chasson zivile äh
Infrastruktur kritische Infrastruktur
und ähm auch Heizkraftwerke etwa
angegriffen werden also das heißt jetzt
im Winter wird die Situation noch einmal
schwieriger und es wird für die Menschen
eben auch immer schwieriger Jobs zu
finden also ihren Lebensunterhalt hasson
zu verdienen dort irgendwie über die
Runden zu kommen das dann noch kommt
alles zusätzlich zu diesem täglichen
Beschuss eigentlich der sehr heftig ist
und das führt dazu dass immer mehr
Menschen die Stadt verlassen bis zu 100
pro Tag im Moment du warst heute mehrere
Stunden in Heron unterwegs in dieser
zerstörten Stadt du hast es gerade schon
ein bisschen angedeutet trotzdem noch
mal die Frage wie viel Alltag ist da
aktuell überhaupt noch möglich was hast
du heute noch
erlebt also von Altag kann man
eigentlich gar nicht mehr sprechen ähm
wie gesagt es ist mittlerweile nur noch
ein Viertel der Bevölkerung in chson es
gibt einige Straßen wo das Leben ein
bisschen normal wirkt da sind Geschäfte
offen da sind Menschen auf der Straße
beispielsweise fahren auch immer noch
Busse aber das sind nur so kleine
Ausschnitte wo es so wirkt als wäre das
Leben normal es gibt ganze Stadtteile
die wirklich völlig verweistß sind vor
allem natürlich um soo weiter man runter
in Richtung nipro kommt in Richtung des
Flusses weil dort eben die Gefahr
aufgrund der russischen Streitkräfte die
ja immer noch auf der anderen Seite des
Flusses stehen besonders hoch ist also
es ist schwierig aber es gibt natürlich
auch so kleine
Begegnungen die wir hatten die dann
wiederum auch zeigen wie resilient diese
Menschen sind also beispielsweise haben
wir ein Wohnhaus gefilmt
was in der vergangenen Nacht getroffen
worden ist eine Rakete ist vor diesem
Wohnhaus eingeschlagen hat die Fassade
zerstört und davor war ein Mann der
versucht hat irgendwie ein bisschen
aufzuräumen weil er in diesem Wohnhaus
unten einen kleinen Laden führt der
wichtig ist für die Menschen der Brot
verkauft etwas Milch und er hat halt
gesagt es hilft ja nichts wir müssen
weitermachen er hat wieder aufgemacht
hat an dem Morgen bereits wieder
verkauft also die Menschen halten sich
an dem bisschen Alltag der möglich ist
auf jeden Fall auch fest wir haben es
jetzt gerade im Gespräch mit Gustav
gressel auch schon gehört diese kleinen
Geländegewinne auf der südlichen Seite
oder östlichen Seite des nipro welche
Hoffnungen verbinden die Menschen in
rerson denn mit die diesen ja offenbar
im Moment noch kleinen aber immerhin
militärischen
Erfolgen wir haben ja heute mit dem
Sprecher der Militärverwaltung in der
Region chzon gesprochen und der hat
gesagt dass es natürlich am allerbesten
wäre wenn es gelingen würde dass durch
diese militärischen Operationen auf der
anderen Seite des nipro es geschafft
wird die Russen mindestens mal 30 km vom
Flussufer wegzudrücken also auch von der
Stadt chson zu entfernen denn das würde
für die Menschen in chson selber eine
große Entlastung bringen ganz einfach
weil die Stadt dann nicht mehr so leicht
mit artilleri geschossen zu erreichen
ist das sind ja gerade das ist ja gerade
dieser Beschuss der dann so unvermittelt
so plötzlich kommt wo man sich dann auf
einmal
in Sicherheit bringen muss irgendwie die
Menschen mit denen wir gesprochen haben
haben uns eigentlich alle erzählt dass
sie große Hoffnung haben dass diese
militärischen Operationen weiterhin
erfolgreich sind weil sie sagen sie sein
erfolgreich im Gegensatz zu dem was die
russische Seite sagt sie hoffen dass
wirklich möglichst bald etwas ruhiger
wird in chasson und viele Menschen auf
der Seite von chasson auf der Seite des
Flusses haben natürlich auch Verwandte
und Bekannte auf der anderen jetzt
russisch besetzten Seite und sie hoffen
dass dann irgendwann vielleicht es auch
möglich sein wird dort äh wieder Kontakt
zu Menschen in etwa in befreiten Dörfern
aufzunehmen und eine Frau hat uns heute
auch erzählt dass bereits Menschen die
akuiert worden sind diese Situation
natürlich ganz besonders beobachten also
z.B Sie anrufen und fragen wie ist es
ist es schon ruhiger geworden in Heron
durch diese militärischen Operation weil
viele ich würde fast sagen fast alle der
Menschen die chon verlassen haben
eigentlich gerarne so schnell wie
möglich zurückkehren
wollen danke dir für diese Eindrücke Tim
Kröger live aus Odessa danke
schön also große Hoffnung für die
Menschen oder bei den Menschen in
hererson dass die ukrainischen Truppen
die russischen Streitkräfte weiter
zurückdrengen können wir wollen jetzt
noch mal fragen wie das denn gelingen
kann und darüber will ich jetzt noch mal
sprechen mit dem Militärexperten Gustav
gressel der mir jetzt hoffentlich wieder
aus Berlin zugeschaltet ist da ist er
Herr gressel warum ist es für die
Ukrainer aktuell so schwierig dort
weiter
vorzurücken das ist in erster Linie eine
Frage des Nachschubs also die Artillerie
auf der ukrainischen Seite steht ja auf
dem rechten Ufer
und unterstützt die Infanterie die am
linken Ufer agiert die Fliegerabwehr die
die Truppen am linken Ufer schützt vor
russischen luftabriffen steht auch am
rechten Ufer desto weiter ich jetzt
vordringe desto mehr muss ich diese
schweren Kräfte nachziehen und da ist
das Problem der Verbindungen
der fairtauglichkeit von Schiffen durch
die Überflutung sind ja auch viele
zivile Schiffe die noch verfügbar waren
in der Region Flussschiffe kaputt
gegangen an Land gespült wordden oder
gesunken das heißt man ein Problem die
die Quantität zu bekommen um auch
wirklich auf dem dass wenn man
Artillerie z.B auf das andere Ufer
ziehen würde die täglich mit Munition zu
versorgen
fliegeabwehr dafür ist ist sozusagen der
ne dann ein ein logistischer
Flaschenhals auch die Kämpfe vorwärts
dass man aus den auwäern bebaute Gebiete
Agrarflächen dahinter das natürlich viel
schwierigeres Gelände um infanteristisch
anzugreifen
die im Besitz zu nehmen das ist für die
Ukrainer
schwierig aber natürlich die die
Hoffnung ist da dass man dadurch dass
eben hier die russischen
Verteidigungsstellungen weit schlechter
vorbereitet sind und die Minenfelder
weit dünner sind dass man hier vor allen
Dingen nach guter Aufklärung noch die
Russen überraschen kann und aushebeln
kann und und weiterkommt ob das gelingt
wird sozusagen werden die nächsten
Wochen und Monate zeigen das kann man
auch nicht wirklich gut vorhersagen das
hängt auch viel von Glück und von
Faktoren an die die selbst sozusagen
gute Planung oft nicht beeinflussen kann
das ist im im Krieg so dass sozusagen es
viele immer viele Chancen und
Möglichkeiten gibt aber nie Sicherheiten
Herr gr ich würde gerne mit Ihnen noch
mal auf die drohen zu sprechen kommen
die wir auch in dem Beitrag von meiner
Kollegin vorhin schon gesehen haben dazu
passt auch eine Frage von Julian shiuma
sehr gut die wir bekommen haben wie ist
es da wird zum einen nach der
lufthohheit an beiden Seiten auf beiden
Fronten gefragt und auch nach der Rolle
von diesen Drohnen eben auch speziell in
diese in dieser Bereich bei
Cherson ja drohen spielen in diesem
Krieg eine enorm wichtige Rolle das
erste Mal zur Aufklärung und zur
Aufklärung von Zielen für die Artillerie
die Artillerie schieß dorthin wo
meistens dorthin wo wo die drohen ihnen
sagen dass der Feind sich befindet sie
haben viel besseren Überblick über die
Lage und können
viel vor all in dieser flachen Gegend
viel
ungehinderter zeigen wo sich andere
Einheiten befinden das zweite ist
natürlich wie es auch sehen hier für
Angriffe und hier werden vor allen
Dingen drohen wie wie sie jetzt gerade
im Bild sehen die also sogenannte first
person virohen also Drohnen wo der
drohnenpilot quasi wie am Flugsimulator
die Rolle des Piloten inne hat und diese
direkt in sealing die können ja auch
Fahrzeuge treffen die sich in Bewegung
befinden die werden mit
panzerabwehrfähigen Granaten ausgerüstet
und dann in Fahrzeuge gelenkt und das
ist sozusagen die
die
Panzerabwehrwaffe die beide Seiten in
sehr hoher Zahl nutzen um mechanisierte
Angriffe abzuwehren und die gepanzerten
Fahrzeuge des gegen also nicht nur
Kampfpanzer auch Schützenpanzer
aufklärungsfahrzeuge
artilleriebeobachtungspanzer
selbstfahrende Artillerie auszuschalten
das ist für die Ukrain jetzt gerade an
diesem Ufer natürlich enorm wichtig weil
diese drohen leichter zu transportieren
sind als viele herkömmliche
panzerabwehrfahrzeuge
der Schütze dieser Drohnen muss ich auch
nicht wie bei einer Panzerabwehrkanone
oder einer herkömmlichen
panzerabwehrlenkwaffe exponieren also
sozusagen wenn sie angreifender Panzer
sind oder Panzerfahrer am Gefechtsfeld
dann sehen sie ja durch den abschussnall
einer Kanone oder durch das aufpfauchen
des raketenmotors
wo die Stellung des anderen ist der auf
mich schießt und wenn er nicht schnell
trifft dann schießt der Panzer für
gewöhnlich zurück bei diesen Drohnen die
werden irgendwo aus den Wald heraus
gestartet das sieht der angreifende
Panzer den Schützen nie
kann ihn deshalb auch nicht niederhalten
oder oder bekämpfen und deshalb ist die
Bedrohung für gepanzerte Fahrzeuge durch
diese durch diese droh Drohnen sehr hoch
äh was die drohen natürlich nicht können
das ist ein Problem für die Ukraine ist
Bewegung ermöglichen ihrerseits weil die
drohen transportieren auch keine anderen
Soldaten die beschleunigen nicht das
Gefecht die verlangsamen es nur immer
auf der Seite des Gegners und beide
Seiten nutzen massiv diese drohen auch
die russische Seite versucht etwa die
Transportschiffe und sturmbote der
Ukrainer die Güter über den nepr
transportieren mit solchen Drohnen
anzugreifen weil sie auch flexibler sind
etwa als Artillerie nicht stuhe Richtung
schießen sondern die Drohne auch mal
sozusagen umdrehen kann sich ein anderes
Ziel vornehmen kann noch mal anfliegen
kann und dann dann eben treffen kann und
man unmittelbar ein Bild bekommt ob man
betroffen hat oder nicht
in dem Sinn spielt auch die
elektronische Kampfführung enorm
wichtige Rolle es sind auf beiden
seitern Störer vorhanden Störsender die
eben versuchen das Steuersignal dann zu
diesem drohnenpiloten zu unterbrechen
dann fliegt die Drohne entweder blind in
den Acker oder setzt sich sozusagen
versucht irgendwie zu ihrem
Ursprungs statgebiet zurückzukehren aber
kann ihre Mission nicht mehr ausführen
Herr gressel worauf kommt es denn dann
jetzt in den kommenden Wochen an dass
eben die Hoffnung die mein Kollege Tim
Kröger der Menschen in Ron eben auch
gerade beschrieben hat dass die nicht
verpufft bzw anders gefragt worauf kommt
es jetzt an aus ukrainische Perspektive
um eben die Stellung südlich des nipro
weiter
auszubauen erstens ist eine Frage wie
viel Nachschub kann die trne in in
dieses Gebiet werfen es sind jetzt sehr
bittere abwehrkämpfer um auf divka aber
auch im im Norden leeman
keminer da greift die russische Armee
wieder unter unter hohen Materialeinsatz
an und auch wenn sie nicht erfolgreich
ist das verlangt den Ukrainer natürlich
auch viel ab sie brauchen
Artilleriemunition da oben um diese
Angriffe abzuwehren sie brauchen den
Einsatz von Panzern es wurden ja schon
Reserven dagegenofensive rausgelöst und
nach aufka und in andere Front s
Schnitte verlegt die fehlen natürlich
jetzt den Ukrainern im Süden um den
Druck auf die Russen aufrecht zu
erhalten
ähm das das ist die eine Frage die
zweite Frage ist natürlich die läst sich
wie gesagt schwer veranstalten das liegt
es in der Hand von sehr lokalen
Kommandeuren
hier auf dem Ufer die die relativ hart
auf sich allein gestellt sind bei diesen
bei diesen kleinen Unternehmungen und
bei diesen Vorstößen eine Lücke eine
Schwachstelle äh im in den russischen
Linien zu finden hineinzustoßen und sie
auszunützen und dann der der des
Vermögens der ukrainischen Armee rasch
weitere Kräfte über den Fluss zu bringen
das ist sozusagen hier ist ein der der
Nebel des Krieges enorm dicht und es ist
für uns enorm schwierig das
vorauszusagen wir würden es natürlich
alle wünschen dass es den Ukrainern gut
gelingt aber äh das hat die
Gegenoffensive ja schon oft gezeigt
es steht oft auf Messers Schneide und
sozusagen von Messer Schneide kann es
dann auch sozusagen in die in die andere
Richtung wieder zurückfallen das ist
schwer vorherzusehen mhm ich würde sie
gerne noch einmal ja um eine kleine
Prognose bitten und zwar wie die Kämpfe
denn jetzt ihrre Einschätzung nach in
den kommenden Wochen weitergehen und
daran noch angeknüpft eine Frage die wir
bei Youtube bekommen haben welche
Auswirkung hätte denn ein sehr kalter
wel ein sehr kalter Winter und wer wäre
dann bei einem sehr kalten Winter im
Vorteil also die zuerst die Prognose äh
ich ich erwarte dass die ukra dass die
russische angriffstätigkeit im Osten
stark zunimmt
es gibt Truppenkonzentrationen im im
Raum der 20 Armee die also aufneute
Angriffe im im nordölichen
Sektor luhansker Oblast
äh deuten hier versuchen die Russen an
den oskilfluss heranzukommen um um sich
dort wahrscheinlich in sehr guten
Verteidigungsstellungen einzurichten
äh ich erwarte auch dass die die
Schlacht um den donescolast noch an
Intensität gewinnt das ist ein Replay
wie gesagt des letzten Jahres die
nächste Winteroffensive
der Russen ich denke dass die Ukrainer
die Geländegewinne
gering halten wird ich denke zwar auch
dass sie divka irgendwann räumen müssen
in in in nächster Zeit oder in den
nächsten Monaten
nichtsdestotrotz die Materialverluste
die personalverluste die sie den Russen
zufügen die die ist das entscheidende
die geben Ihnen dann im nächsten
Frühling Handlungsspielräume
selbstoffensiv tätig zu werden
ein sehr harter kalter Winter
würde im Grunde es ermöglichen beiden
Parteien ermöglichen offensiven
vorzutragen wenn der Boden tief gefroren
ist hart gefroren ist kann ich selbst äh
auch bei nassen etwa versunfteng Gelände
mit gepanzerten Fahrzeugen fahren weil
weil er ausreichend dick gefroren ist
allerdings ist es in den letzten Jahren
sehr selten vorgekommen also der
Klimawandel macht ja auch V der Ukraine
nicht halt und gerade im Süden wo das
asofsche Meer und das Schwarze Meer nah
ist die das Meer macht das so ein
eigenes Mikroklima das den Winter
normalerweise abmildert es sind eben
wirklich dick und fest
tiefgefrorene Böden und auch zugefrorene
Lüsse etwas etwas enorm seltenes anders
ist es im dones und luhansk dort
sozusagen ist das Klima etwas etwas
kälter ich ich denke aber trotzdem dass
vor allen Dingen starker Regen und vor
allen Dingen diese wechselperioden
zwischen Tauwetter und Frost die
Bewegungen eher einschränken werden
auch also wir haben das im letzten
Winter auch oft gesehen drohenbilder
etwa von russischen Soldaten die sich äh
in diesen Bedingungen selbst das Leben
nehmen äh das ist für die Soldaten äh
das Schlimmste jetzt in den
Schützengräben Schnee kann man
rausschaufeln Eis kann man entfernen
aber dieses Wasser das dann in der Nacht
gefriert und bei bei Minusgraden äh die
die durch näste Kleidung dann
durchgefrieren lässt das ist für die
Gesundheit der Soldaten und für äh für
ihre Stellungen das grauenhafteste also
das sind jetzt gerade die dies diese
Herbstmonate und dann auch wieder die
frühen Frühlingsmonate es sind es sind
die allerhärteste Zeit und da ist mit
leider Gottes auch mit sehr vielen
Kranken mit sehr vielen Toten durch
Erfrierungen zu
rechnen Gustav gressel Militärexperte
vom European Council on Foreign
Relations vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit und
für die Einschätzung heute abend vielen
herzlichen Dank soweit unser ZDF heute
live mit dem Ukraine Update in dieser
Woche aktuelle Infos und Hintergründe
zum ukrainekrieg findet ihr wie immer in
der ZDF heute App danke euch für heute
fürs zuschauen für eure Fragen und
Gedanken und bis zum nächsten
Mal